if i come up to a person they're lying
down and i realize that they don't have
pulses
i should immediately start doing cpr a
lot of people tell you to do them to the
beat of staying alive by the beegees so
imagine like really pumping on
somebody's chest saying huh uh
i'm staying alive
hey i'm dr italo brown emergency
physician in palo alto california today
we're going to try to debunk some of the
myths about your health
and some of the things that you've been
using on a day-to-day basis that might
not be so good
you can't die from a broken heart broken
heart syndrome is real
you can actually die from a broken heart
we got a really nifty
japanese name for it called takatsubo
cardiomyopathy the word takasubo
is describing a pot like an octopus pot
the heart takes on the shape of that
octopus pot in these situations where
you have
intense feelings you have stress that is
applied
instantaneously so imagine answering the
phone to find out that a loved one is
passed
it can cause somebody's heart to
actually change
shape the the ventricles or the the part
that forces blood around the body
can bow out like a balloon and we call
that epical ballooning when that
heart starts to change shapes it can
lead to something that's not
common or native to the heart and that
can lead to a sudden death
we tend to follow the same regimen that
we would follow for someone who comes in
with other chest pain like features
specifically severe chest pain
anyone who has an emotional response who
is sentient has
the capacity to have this issue you
should put butter
on a burn you should definitely not put
butter
on a burn we're not baking bread it's
probably one of the worst things to put
on a burn
in most pre-hospital management of burns
we do not recommend using any creams
any lotions whatever else is in your
refrigerator do not put that on a burn
those chemicals can actually worsen the
surface
that is burned the most severe burns
that i worry about
are ones that happen to the areas of the
face
the hands the groin these burns
can potentially damage a lot of other
underlying function and can lead to
long-term dysfunction
so if that happens come to the emergency
department immediately
depending on the surface area covered a
burn wound
can actually draw water from the body
and leave you dehydrated so it's
important to have
adequate hydration which is why we admit
a lot of folks who have
complicated burns of second degree or
third degree nature
the most common thing that we say do is
put it under cold water
and then try to isolate that injury
cracking your knuckles
is bad cracking your knuckles doesn't
necessarily lead to any bad outcomes
most of us were told this is kids
because it was just annoying it didn't
have anything to do with the real
medical element to it
the sound that we hear though is
something that frightens people
or is awkward we're usually uh
thinking that that's bone on bone action
when in factuality it's about the fluid
in between the joints so
synovial fluid helps to lubricate those
joints
when we crack our knuckles it's really
just an air pocket being burst
and that's what the sound is most folks
believe that
putting pressure on joints or or
consistently cracking these joints
will lead to some form of arthritis and
that's not necessarily true
we understand that arthritis is usually
a condition that develops over time and
whether you crack your knuckles or not
it can still happen when you start to
crack other parts of the body and joints
some of them actually are super
relieving you know cracking the hip that
may make someone feel extremely better
and move around a little bit more agile
when cracking is accompanied by
pain that may be an indicator to go see
uh your normal physician and then in
some cases it may even require an
orthopedist or
physical therapy i typically don't
recommend cracking your neck because
if you're pushing your neck beyond this
normal range of motion
you might be stretching blood vessels
that are surrounding that
and cause a rupture that way so it's not
so much the cracking sound but it's the
motion
and the exertion of force that can lead
to a secondary issue
i would recommend just stretching and
you know crack your knuckles
sometimes you know you need that
[Music]
cpr is effective if someone flatlines
cpr is an extremely useful procedure as
part of basic life support
i think that it's extremely valuable for
people to know how to do basic life
support
particularly compressions because of all
the things that we know
this actually saves lives flatlining is
an absence of cardiac activity
when you look at a cardiac monitor most
people describe it as
that sound with the flat line across
we're talking about the actual heart
electrical activity like cpr is an
entire process
whereas what we're discussing
specifically are chest compressions
that's the hand over hand applying force
to the external portion of the body to
create that force to drive blood around
doing that compressions adding
ventilation or breathing in somebody's
mouth or using a breathing aid
to apply oxygen to the lungs and then
doing this
in succession to eventually bring
someone back
or regain pulses regain cardiac activity
if i come up to a person they're lying
down
and i realize that they don't have
pulses i should immediately start doing
cpr
and these compressions are supposed to
be about
two inches deep and they're supposed to
be fast like rapid compressions
so i almost expect in that first
compression
to break through ribs because you need
to create enough force
to push blood flow around the entire
body a lot of people tell you to do them
to the beat of staying alive by the bee
gees so
imagine like really pumping on
somebody's chest saying huh
i'm staying alive that's pretty much
what we do someone who is trained as a
first responder or who has received
basic life support training
can initiate cpr cpr when done
properly can actually resuscitate people
tilting your head back will stop the
nose bleed so most people instinctively
think to
lean their head back as if they're
trying to like use gravity to keep the
blood from going down
their nose but really it's pulling it
down the back part of the nose the
nasopharynx
and that directly connects to your
airway so
if the bleeding is so profuse or so
brisk that it's filling up the mouth it
can
compromise your breathing that's
dangerous so we typically tell people to
lean
forward and pinch their nose really hard
with most bleeding
the goal is to apply pressure to the
direct side of the bleed
and because you can't reach into the
nose and actually like tap down the
artery
we usually recommend grabbing the
cartilaginous or the cartilage portion
of the nose
instead of the bridge there are
different reasons why nose bleeds can
occur the most common reason
is direct trauma or irritation of some
part of the membranes
inside the nose so they're like small
capillaries there that can rupture
the main goal is does the bleeding stop
by just applying
pressure it's completely manageable at
home however if you start to have like
worsening symptoms like repeat or
recurrent bleeds
lightheadedness dizziness if the
bleeding is extremely quick
you need to get in a car and go to the
emergency department but don't tilt your
head back in the car
a migraine is just a bad headache this
is not necessarily
false but it's poor understanding of the
difference between migraines and
headaches so when we think about
headaches in general
this is tension in the head it can be
something that is pounding or pulsating
the difference with the migraine though
is we're talking about multiple hours
to days of unrelenting pain the main
characteristic is that this is extremely
painful
and debilitating it stops your normal
function of activities
which is why we treat them so seriously
when you talk about migraines
you can have a simple migraine or
complex migraine we usually think about
complex migraines as having an aura
or other features that are more
sensitory to them
besides just the pain element you might
feel dizziness
you might feel ringing in the ears or
some visual changes blurry vision these
things come
with complex migraines and it can be
extremely debilitating
so if you're at home and you start to
feel that migraine
uh build up a little bit i usually
recommend that someone goes to a very
quiet space in their home
turn off all the lights take their
standard medications and drink some
water
sometimes caffeine helps so people will
drink a tall cup of coffee
to help abate some of those symptoms
those are simple things that you can do
at home
to try to treat a migraine but if it
ever lasts longer than four or six hours
after you do this or several days of you
trying these preventative measures
come see us vaping is safe
this is a hundred percent false vaping
is not safe
we know that vaping is a trendy thing
now that people are doing this is
electronic cigarettes
usually it's got some type of a
cartridge with uh nicotine as a product
mixed in with other products and
compounds so that you can aerosolize it
inhaling we started to realize
that it is so extremely harmful that it
can lead to
long hospital admissions and icu stays
one of the things that people have
traced the particular hazards of vaping
too is vitamin e a lot of these
compounds
that people are putting in to uh the
cartridge and fluid of
a vaping pen haven't been studied well
that vitamin e compound
has been known to destroy the small air
pockets of the lung known as alveoli
this is where the harm starts we call
that acute
lung injury we know that this leads to
people having severe lung dysfunction
we understand that it also ruins the
lungs ability to
actually grab oxygen from the
bloodstream because
of that material that's coating the
alveoli most people
switch from tobacco to this product
because
they find that they want to be less
likely to have
a lung cancer but still need nicotine
because there is an addiction to
nicotine that is why it was initially
thought as a harm reduction measure it
actually increases the type of harm that
you can have it just shifts it over from
one type to another if you do have
nicotine addiction and you need help
stopping uh that particular craving
there are so many programs
that will work with you to figure out
like do you need just counseling
is there a need for a medication
assistance or
patches these are known ways to curb the
appetite
of nicotine i don't recommend vaping i
think that is
harmful i think that it is a habit that
can lead to someone losing their life or
their ability
to breathe freely so put the pins down
y'all
vick's vaporub can be used anywhere
on the body these mentholated topical
ointments
cannot be used in every location in the
body
specifically they cannot be ingested
if you even look at one of the canisters
it has a warning label
that says do not swallow this i know
this because i've watched my grandfather
he used to swallow a nice little dab of
vicks as well as rub it all over his
chest and underneath his nose
he said it helped him fight a cold well
now that i'm an er physician
i've heard those same stories but they
don't always end the same way
so i don't recommend using vix vapor rub
in other locations then already
designated
by the manufacturers i also don't
recommend ingesting
anything that has the toxic property
camp for that's the key element you have
to read the labels
just put it on your chest walk around
smelling like you're 78 years old
it's fine an apple a day keeps the
doctor away
this is one of the most ridiculous
things i've ever heard
if it was that easy to keep doctors away
uh i promise you apples wouldn't cost 59
cents they'd be
far more expensive if you're just
literally basing it on a granny smith
apple
let me tell you right now that's not
gonna work the only thing that i can
think of right off the bat
that you can do daily that helps your
immune system
is to eat a well-rounded meal and that
goes for children
all the way through older adults all the
necessary nutrients
you have all your macromolecules in it
some serving of fruits vegetables
maybe a little bit of grain some form of
protein something that's going to
give you the building blocks that your
body needs to do the processes through
the day
to keep you moving
dr italo brown just reminding you guys
take your health seriously
be careful about the information that
you hear floating around if it sounds
weird
if it has some type of odd little story
to it chances are
it might not be true we only have one
body it's important
to know what you put on your body in
your body let's go ahead and talk to our
doctors and have a good conversation
with them
and you do everything in your power to
stay informed